Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I am your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Okay, today's Native Hook.
The Native Hook is a good conversation piece that you can use with people...
...and make the conversation exciting.
Today's topic is about:...
..."Who pays for lunch or dinner?"
So, when you eat out and you order lots of food,...
...and it comes time for somebody to pay,...
...in Japan, a lot of people go Dutch.
You pay pretty exactly how much you ate for.
But in the States, we don't really do that so often.
We basically buy for each other.
We basically pay for each other because,...
...you know, it goes around.
And a lot of times, a lot of people pay for you.
And at the end, you pay too.
So there's a good balance.
So that's a little difference between the States and Japan.
Alright.
Okay, today's Maestro Menu.
It's on me.
It's on me today.
I'll get you the next time.
Okay.
Okay. So next, Maestro Lines.
Hey guys! It's on me today.
Oh thanks! Okay, I'll get you the next time.
Okay, that's it for today.
Thanks for watching AERA English TV...
...and I'll see you next week. Bye-bye!